we will be starting in about
30 seconds
and welcome everyone
to our digital marketing master class
researching keywords for seo paid in
content marketing
um our instructor today is matt
bailey he is the founder and president
of sitelogic marketing he is a digital
marketing faculty member at simply learn
i'm stewart creek i'm a
marketing manager here at simply learn
i'll just be in the background
helping run the slides and
polls and
if you would like to ask questions for
matt
best way is to put them in the q a
function
we will be cataloging those and a few of
them will take live
a few we'll take at the end in the
q a section of the webinar you can also
enter
information in the chat make sure you
address it to all panelists that's the
only way that
we'll be sure that matt can see it as
well and
as i mentioned we will be doing some
polls the first one
here is
two questions
and for those of you on webex you'll see
the poll widget pop
up for those of you watching on live
streaming
um you can put answers in the chat
or comments uh how much work experience
do you have
and we also ask how are you feeling
today
because of the stresses of the last year
and a half
i want to check in with everybody on
that and um
we'll give you about another 10 seconds
to answer the poll
and the results
so we have a fairly even mix of
experience we have
people ranging from college students all
the way up to
seasoned professionals with more than 10
years experience
and the good thing is that
nearly everybody is doing at least okay
and
most of everybody is doing uh well for
the few who are
not we're in the thumbs down category we
hope that this
webinar will give you some information
that will help
improve your mood and so
with that i'm going to introduce the
fellow you see before you
um matt bailey he's the president of
sitelogic
he is a digital marketing instructor for
the direct marketing association in new
york city
an instructor for the omcp program
and author of internet marketing an hour
a day
wired to be wowed and teach an old dog
new tricks
and as i mentioned he is a key member of
the faculty here at
simply learn so we're very pleased to
have him here today for this event
welcome matt and i will turn the event
over to you
oh let me unmute you
or you can unmute you hey thank you so
much stuart i appreciate the opportunity
to be here
and thank you everyone for attending
this webinar
uh this was a a little different
approach typically to what you've seen
we're not going to do a lot of slides
uh rather this is going to be a
demonstration
because i if i were to sum up the
one skill that digital marketers
need to have regardless of where your
focus or your concentration might be
the root of everything in digital
marketing
is keyword research when i had my agency
uh i had an agency for around 10 years
when we would get a new client we would
do
keyword research for at least four to
five days on this client now of course
if they were e-commerce
they had products and so it would last a
lot longer uh
but at its core we would focus on
finding everything relevant about
this client about their business and
what are people saying
and we would examine the keywords in
many different ways
in order to come up with really
so that we would be the experts on the
keywords for this client
we didn't rely on the client to tell us
everything about their business we went
online to see what other people
said and what the keywords said and what
people were looking for
so by the end of this keyword research
project every analyst who is
working for this client was intimately
familiar with the words that people use
so in doing this we could create better
optimization
we could create better paid search
campaigns
we could create better content in the
content marketing plan
because we knew what people wanted and
more importantly we knew the words
that they used and that is what is so
critical about keyword research
i love it to me it is the heartbeat of
digital marketing because we use these
words and
we use the intelligence that we find in
so many other areas so i'm going to
point them out as we go along
and i'm just going to walk through a
project
as if i were starting fresh with a new
client or
or someone to find out just how would i
start
and what would we do so that's what
we're going to
walk through today and uh if you have
specific questions
about keyword research go ahead and put
that in the chat
i may not see it because i'm looking at
another screen
as we go through this uh but stuart's
gonna keep an eye on the chat here and
let me know
uh as some questions appear now i'm
gonna go ahead
and i'm going to share my screen here
stuart if i can have the uh
the share button
yes yeah i and i told you before as we
were in the practice session that i
would forget to do something like that
that's all right that's all right
now okay
and let me make sure that is good all
right so
you should be seeing my second screen
here and hopefully everything is still
working with the video and the screen
and so this is where typically i start
now there are
many keyword research programs
they are all a software as a service
i use word tracker word tracker is
probably the one that i have used the
longest
and i continue to use it i love the
results that i get from it
moz has a keyword research
tool ahrefs uh raven tools
i mean if you just go to google and type
in keyword
research tools or keyword research
software you'll probably get a dozen or
more and so
that's you know you find one that you
like
uh many of them will offer a free trial
and so that is very very helpful to get
a sense of how it works
and what you can do with it so i suggest
you take advantage
of those free trials to see which one is
going to suit you
also different keyword research tools
um will offer different levels in the
upgrade so now i pay for
a higher level so that i can get
keywords from other countries and other
languages
that is also part of this not everything
is english
and most of these companies are based in
the us
so you want to be sure if you're in a
regional or a different country
that the keyword research tool you
select has
searches that are native to your country
to your language because that is a vital
part of optimization as well as doing
your keyword research
so as you can see here i'm going to walk
through the interface and
just kind of show you some of the
functions that are available here
now one of the first things i like about
word tracker and what i can do is i can
not only search google
now let's let's start with a couple of
myth busting aspects here number one
on any keyword research tool
it doesn't matter who they are nobody
has a direct relationship with google
and can
access 100 percent of all google
searches
all right anyone is you anyone who
offers keyword research
and offers a google option they are
using
an api and they are getting a
small percentage of the actual searches
done on google
there's no way anyone is seeing
the full amount of keyword searches done
on google
in fact even those of you who know those
of you who do paid
search campaigns in google when you go
research
keywords in google you don't even see
the full breadth of searches and the
full the accurate search counts or
anything like that so google does not
share its entire
search database all right any keyword
research engine
is only getting a small fraction of the
data
and they are extrapolating that now
they're also cross
referencing it with other data from isps
from browsers from many other sources to
try and bring that in
and essentially what they do is create
an algorithm
and that algorithm will give us
estimates on how many searches are done
that month
all right now next i can also here's
what i love about this i can also search
based on amazon so they also get
feeds from amazon to look at that
youtube and ebay so depending upon uh
what you're doing and what your client
looks like or what
what you're doing it can help to do some
keyword research because you will
find that people search differently on
youtube
than they do on google people search
differently on
amazon than they do on google and amazon
it's all
product driven in google it's a lot of
information driven
uh on youtube it's it's a little bit of
both but people are actually looking for
advice and comparison
so youtube is a very interesting way of
researching keywords
i'm going to stay with google and i'll
show you here so the keyword that i
entered for researching a little bit
more about is
hiking boots this is one i've done a lot
in travel and tourism
and worked with an outfitter
many years ago and this is one area that
i just enjoy working with and
because it's got a very broad range of
keywords
now we've got our keywords here and
now i can also choose the specific
territory
now as you can see here uh i'm looking
for us-based keywords
and i've got a full range of other
countries that i can search for
as well and see uh if i want to focus
down on a specific country
or specific area i can do that
now i've put in hiking boots
and as we can see here what happens is
now i have 734
keywords uh about hiking boots
now what this has done i'm going to
click on this little tool over here this
little gear icon
now this should help you those of you
familiar with paid search
i have two options to search with here i
have a broad
match method and an exact match method
i usually go for the broad all right
because i want to know
all of the related terms that people are
using
when they search for this i'm at the
very beginning of
the process now my approach to this
when i'm at the beginning of research i
want
as many words as possible i'm trying to
get
everything i can and so
i'm going to use that broad match option
and i love seeing that i have hundreds
of words
related to this i like it even more when
i see thousands
because i really want to get a sense of
how broad
the scope is when people are searching
so to give a sense here where we're at
the first option here
as we can see is is hiking boots for
women and that is the first option
that's available
now here's how we read this these
columns here
the first thing and i'm going to talk a
little bit more about this and this is
the historical
performance now what you see here in the
volume
column that is the average the
average amount of searches every month
averaged for an entire year now what
that means
is it averages in this case 135 000
searches per month
however though that's not true
every month it's just an average so what
we get
here in the historical it shows the
trend
now later on i you know i'll probably
bring up google trends
as well to get a sense of how some of
these keywords perform in google trends
don't always get the same data in google
trends sometimes it changes depending
upon how much
they are allowing you to see but this
gives me a sense here of showing that
there is a
significant trend that it's at its
lowest
in the january february and march time
frame
and then it increases and i can see here
uh starting probably around may
june now it's above average uh
until around the end of the summer and
then it drops off again
so the historical trend line is very
helpful to show
that it's not every month you get 135
000 searches
it changes now that's something that you
need to keep in mind
that if you're doing paid search you're
going to see lower volumes
so you may want to adjust your strategy
adjust your budget accordingly
this also lets you know from an seo
standpoint when is the big trend
if i know the big trend hits around this
this
this may june time frame well then that
lets me know that i need to have content
on my site and optimized
if i want it to be found in that trend
also from a social media standpoint
when when do people start asking
questions when do people start
investigating i can see here now i know
the trend
so now i know on social media when to
start talking
and linking from my social media posts
how-to
things uh you know different product
guides i can start publishing them ahead
of the trend
because i know when people are more
actively talking about things
so you can see there's a lot we can
learn already about these keywords
just from starting to do the initial
look
now i'll tell you right now the best
tool
all right there and i'm gonna
everything's the best tool
if you've if you've heard me ever any
length of time at all i love bringing in
tools
i will tell you the best thing you can
do i love digital
but here is the best tool that i have
when i'm doing keyword research
it is a notepad and a pen because
you are going to get ideas you're going
to see things that you're going to want
to investigate
later you're going to get ideas and the
best thing to have is just a notepad and
pen
sitting on your desk so as you see these
things
you write them down so that you know to
go back and do it again later
don't rely on your memory you're going
to be taking in a lot of
information a lot of information
and you're going to see things so just
like what i was saying is i see this
trend
i want to write the trend down i want to
write down how will it apply in my seo
how will it apply in my paid how would
it apply in my content marketing my
social
and also how will it apply in my
analytics
if i'm looking at trends and i'm looking
at keywords and i'm looking at this
well this should tell me that my product
pages
should increase in traffic around the
may june time
frame i should expect that and so from
an analytics standpoint
i know it to look for because i know
when the trend happens
it doesn't mean all of a sudden that
your seo is bringing in a lot more
people
because that's the trend you should be
found more your traffic
should increase for those product pages
so i hope that's clear so far what we've
covered stu
do we have any questions specifically
about what i've covered at this point
yeah we have a couple um one of them
first off is
if the web tracker word tracker tool is
a free tool or a paid tool
it is a paid tool but it does have a
uh sort of a a free or a limited
trial or an option that you can try it
okay
um and denisha
asks if the first data that you're
showing
in this table um in the results here
is this how many
women's searches are uh
come up on google or is this um
as you can to clarify that as you
mentioned it's an average okay yeah
so what this is is these are the words
that are typed into the google search
bar
and what i'm looking for are all what
this shows me here are all the
variations
of the term hiking boots with words in
front
and behind and so that's all i'm asking
is when people type in
hiking boots into google how many
variations
are there now i know there's a lot more
so i know google's not giving up a lot
of information
and and word tracker is kind of
extrapolating what it can
so i'm probably looking at about 20
of the available market of what's going
on
so this just shows me the variations
that
people type into google so as you can
see here
yeah so i've got hiking boots for women
hiking boots women
hiking boots women's so it's all the
variations that people type
in uh of the word hiking boots
and the related words around it right
um by the way word tracker
vikrant says word tracker doesn't uh
data for india
so which of the other tools you
mentioned might be
better for the indian practitioner
that is a great great question yeah i
don't see that here
wow uh i know that uh
simply learn which is based in
bangalore uses ahrefs
and um seo rush
among other tools so yep those are
those are some of the options but yeah
those are both very good tools
um it's just a matter of preference and
and what you want to use
um i think you can i think i can upgrade
and get
india in my word tracker a lot of them
will offer
tiers like you pay a certain amount and
you get english you pay another amount
and you get
country specific uh and if you want
everything
there's like a top tier so that's how a
lot of them will monetize but yeah
ahrefs
um and um i forget the other one uh you
mentioned
ahrs is probably um probably
one of the most aggressive as far as
gathering keywords from around the world
in different countries
so yeah for india i would definitely
recommend that
and uh just to be clear gopal asks
if there is any way to get the exact
search numbers
which
there is no way ever
that we will ever see the exact search
counts
and the exact words they're using in
google as a as i mentioned
even if you are working in google in a
paid campaign
and you use google's keyword research
tool
google doesn't even show you the full
breadth of
searches and how many searches they give
you
a a sort of a rounded down figure
um and and really they what google is
doing
is they will merge for example a
singular
and a plural word together and so you're
not getting
individual search counts for the
singular word or the plural word
you're getting a single search count and
because google wants you to bid on one
word
and they will connect you to others so
it's it's interesting what google is
doing with keywords they are taking away
more and more data every year
and giving giving site owners seos
less and less information specifically
about keywords
uh to work with so yeah it's a
diminishing resource right now
one last point before we go on is um
we have a question that says if you are
going to look up track and boot
uh for different search platforms do you
need to run the search
four separate times like once for google
once for amazon once for youtube
yes yeah those are all separate projects
now i can
add all those words um so
a great question because this brings me
into the next section here
so i can create a new list um i'm going
to create a new list here
and i'm going to call this my my
keyword project and i'm going to
and please don't comment on my spelling
this is live all right and i'm a
terrible typer
um and i will call this my my hiking
boots project
all right i don't know what happened
there so they'll
all right so that's my project there so
as i go through here and see all of my
keywords
i'm going to go through and select
everything that i see that is
relevant to what i'm looking for so if i
am
selling hiking boots if i am an
outfitter here i'm very interested to
see
all of these now shortcut
i'm going to click keyword and
everything
uh highlights here and i can just go
through and take a look at the different
kinds of
things that we have here and yeah i'm
like all of these
i need to know all of this so what i can
do there
is i can save these
and i can put them into my
that selected list my keyword project
hiking boots and i want to add to that
list
now individually when you click on these
as well it will add to the list
so now i as i can see here i have a
number of pages here i'll go to page two
and i'll see all of the keywords that
are there
and i believe i added everything to that
so let me save that
here's my list there
add to that list so yeah i've got all
734 words in that in that list
now what i can do to
really maybe i want to filter down i can
look in this
included keywords here and i can say
show me all the keywords of for example
boots for women
so now i'm looking at hiking boots and
just
must also include the word women so now
i can filter this down think about it in
terms of an e-commerce site if i'm going
to sell
shoes or boots i'm going to divide by
women's and men's
and this now shows me the different
keywords that are being used
uh that have to include the word women's
so i've got all the hiking boots for
women
now this is where i start seeing
some differences about how to apply
these words
so for example hiking boots for women
these are
all in these are all product searches
someone is
the very beginning of the buying cycle
they're
just starting to learn about them and
this is what they type in so
kind of your first five or six are just
a very
general term people are starting now
look at these next three and and i'm
gonna actually take off that keyword
check so we can look at these three now
this is the next stage in the buying
cycle
the next stage is i want to know the
best
so what they are looking for are
articles reviews
they're looking for more in-depth
information than just
what shoes are available they're looking
for
someone's opinion about why these are
the best
so that should get your you know your
attention
from a content marketing standpoint this
is content people want they want to know
what are the best so if you are selling
these
you should have an opinion about what
are the best boots
why why do what makes them the best you
have that expertise if you're selling
them and you know about them
then your expertise is what people want
and so when you see best that is a great
indicator of
content that people want to see on your
site now
not just from an article this would make
a great youtube video
as well having someone explain here's
our top three or top
five and here's what makes them great
build a script
give information people are looking for
that so that should let you know from a
content marketing standpoint right away
this is something people want now
as we get further down into the list
here
we start seeing some ways that we can
start
categorizing all of these boots
all right and so number one i can start
categorizing by
by men's and women's i i saw that here
and i'm gonna make that note here in my
notes
but also the next stage here is
check this out what we have
you know what these are brand names
this next stage here is brand name so
people started looking at the very
general
then they want to know the best now what
shows up next are brand names so
we need to make a note of that so
especially from
a paid search standpoint if i am
advertising these products in paid
search
it is vitally important to include the
brand names
uh either in the ad itself or in
the uh in the extensions that i have
these brands and i offer them so that as
people are searching for them
they can see that direct link right in
to the extension
all right let me uncheck those
so that's what i'm looking for as i'm
going through the large
list i'm looking for opportunities to
really categorize here so i've
categorized i've got brands
i've got best so people are looking for
some level of comparison
um and now i'm seeing so like black so
people are looking for
color uh oh this is interesting
someone's looking for
cute hiking boots for women so now i can
start another category for
attributes attributes of
boots and under attributes that's where
i'll put you know
color like black or cute uh as someone's
looking for here
um now also we'll start seeing other
things here like
leather or outdoor
um which i would think you know
hiking boots are outdoor to begin with
but people are going to use those words
so
it's good to know how people utilize
these words and and what they're putting
in here
we're also seeing light weight so this
is what i'm looking for
i'm looking for the adjectives that
people use to describe
the core phrase that i'm optimizing for
and so this helps as i'm going down
through here
uh here's another one for brown uh
here's another color
um another attribute stylish uh
so what i'm learning here as
i'm building product descriptions or
product pages
i can come up with a description but
from the
keyword research people are telling me
what they're looking for
they're providing a pattern of what i
can learn and how i can
optimize the content and so i want to
keep that in mind as i'm going through
here
and that will you know it'll help me
write better descriptions it'll help me
create
better titles and headlines as i am
going through
my site all right so i'm looking through
here and it's giving me
a lot of good ideas as i'm going through
here now by the way
oh by the way yes i had a question
that's uh appropriate to this section um
and andre asks why would you not do a
persona analysis or
identity search uh search intent
analysis
before you start idea generation of
keywords
and i bet i know what you're going to
say um like at this point all i'm trying
to do is get everything
possible and then i want to organize it
and we're not at the persona stage
yet okay uh the persona stage
it comes a little bit later so for
example i'll show you here
um here's a key word for vegan hiking
boots
now that lets me know
that indicates i might want to research
that persona i want to look more at that
right now i'm just trying to get a sense
of the keyword universe
that surrounds hiking boots uh i'm
letting the market
tell me what they want
so rather than i i find that if i were
to do
a persona or something first i'm going
to approach this
with some preconceived ideas about who
my personas are
to me keyword research is a listening
exercise it's listening to
a hundred people in a room tell you what
they think
and all i'm doing is soaking it in i'm
soaking in as much information as
possible
i don't want to approach this with some
preconceived ideas or
identities i just want to know
what are people thinking and what are
they typing into google
and then i'll develop it from there now
as i go deeper into my categorization
so for example if i'm looking for um
you know i'm looking for colors i'm
seeing attributes
those types of things now i'll start
going deeper into the different
categories
and from there we'll look at how to
apply a persona
or something like that uh because now
we've got
keywords that that persona would use and
i would apply them
that way rather than and then and then
going about it but
i'll tell you this whatever works for
you there are no rules to this
all right this is you do
what works for you um and and if you
find that that helps you
think better or it gives you more
clarification
as or direction then do it uh
this is just you know this is my process
that i've developed so
there's no wrong well it might be a
wrong answer here or there
uh but there's no there's there's no
hard and fast rules about keyword
research
that's a great great question
an excellent answer also um and one
other
just minor thing that came up um
you had a question about how
minor variations typos or um
the difference between women and women's
affect
uh the results in the
keyword research great great question
that used to be a lot more important
probably 10 or more years ago um
ten or more years ago i obsessed over
plurals uh i obsessed over
you know women's boots or boots for
women
uh you know that apostrophe s
15 years ago i would optimize
specifically for those different
variations because
it meant something completely different
as far as intent
um we used to map this out because
if someone is searching for a plural
it means they're at the beginning
they're looking for the broad
area of what they want if someone would
search
singular it means they're looking for
one
and they're further on in the buying
cycle now
fast forward now to 2021 google
has put this all on its head
and according to google someone
searching for plural and singular
is exactly the same um and so they've
taken away the data for us to see
the amount of searches for singular and
plural they also treat that
intent as being exactly the same and so
their algorithm
regardless of you optimized for women or
women's
is going to yield the same type
of result according to their algorithm
it all means the same
thing um very similar to
no long i i haven't optimized for
misspellings
uh not since the 90s
because google does a very good job if
you type a misspelling into google or
any other search engine
they'll immediately show you the
corrected spelling and
they'll show you the results for the
corrected spelling of that word
so don't optimize for misspellings um
and if i see those in there
i just look at that as what would be the
actual word rather than the misspelling
so great great questions good all right
thanks so much yeah absolutely so
now i i just added these into my keyword
project and and here's what i'm going to
do i'm
um when i when i look at that now i can
do this within the keyword
tool um let me take out my excluded
keywords
um i can look at a couple things here
now by the way some of the columns
here's what you're going to see
uh the competition so the competition
here
uh it shows you the amount of
competition of websites
uh that are using these words so for
example
uh hiking boots here has a 33.97
that means there is a high level of
competition
for that phrase and there should be it's
a very general
it's the top for you know the general
phrase that's there
whereas check this out hiking boots
women's
that combination has a very low
competition it's only
3.9 so this gives you a sense of how
many websites are
optimizing and using those terms
and it gives you a sense of what the
competition level is
if you were to start optimizing for that
now how are they
uh what's the competition look like this
next column the iaat
this means that they are spidering the
sites that are ranking for these words
and how many websites are using that
keyword
and iat in anchor and title
this means that that keyword is being
used in anchor text
and it's being used in the page title
that's how we know that someone is
actively optimizing for these phrases
and that's what helps us understand the
competition level
so that's what's going on there all
right now
what i do now i'm seeing all these
phrases here
you can either do this in an excel
spreadsheet
or you can do this here um
i like to do this in the excel
spreadsheet now i'm going to open it up
here in excel
because i show you kind of how i like to
deal with this
all right and it's not looking at
everything here um
let me go back to this
export
all right i bring this over here
and now we're in probably one of my
favorite tools and that is
microsoft excel as you can see it has
exported just about everything here but
i don't need
everything at this point right now so
what i'm going to do is
actually delete these columns because i
i can go back and get those
i can save that uh as another option
here
there we go and i'm gonna i'm gonna
delete the content there
now i'm gonna organize at this point and
i
and i will start with just a basic
understanding so
uh i i can make some initial categories
so women's uh
men's and i can also look at
searches that can have a brand name
i can also look at attributes
like color or feature or something like
that
uh and then also i'm going to look at
uh and i'm gonna make a column here for
content
so for example like i saw best
uh people are looking for best they're
looking for a comparison and so
i'm gonna make a column so that
everything for example in women's men's
brand name attributes
those are things that i'll use for my
optimization
i'm going to use those phrases and use
those words to implement in the website
when i see people asking questions
like best i'm gonna put that in my
content plan
in my content marketing plan so i'm
gonna make another column of
questions people have uh what do they
wanna know
what are things they're searching for
because if i have the expertise or i
know where to go
get the expertise i want to add that
into my plan and so i'm going to add
that
off to here and i'm going to keep that
so that you know and what i'll typically
do
is so for example women's were like the
top here
i'm gonna copy them and put them over
here
so i've got a good sense now of
the women's specifically and then these
next ones
uh men's make up these next groups
i'm gonna copy them and put them over
here
and like i said the next word
got some brand names
and then here's my best phrases
and i'm copying that over so i've got
the keywords as well as their counts i
want to keep an eye on that
uh so that i know what's going on here
now uh
this is interesting because this now
helps me i've got
waterproof hiking boots women now i'm
starting to get attributes as well as my
core phrase here
this is where i kind of like playing
around with the keywords
um because this gives me a little bit
sent a sense of how people
formulate phrases what i'm looking for
here and and let me just take a quick
look at
some of this to see um
if it confirms see what i'm seeing here
yeah so example here yeah let me grab
that
i'm gonna put that up here
now one of the things i like doing just
to help me understand the
as i drill down into categories here is
my core phrase
is hiking boots
that's my core phrase i'm going to
center that here so i have a better idea
what's going on
now also what i'm looking at and and
this just helps me to understand a
little bit from a search perspective
and especially if you have an e-commerce
site with hundreds
or hundreds of thousands of products
this may help because what i'm looking
for here is a feature attribute
model that i can apply to these products
so right away i know that when it comes
to hiking boots
um and let me play around with the
columns a little bit here to help me
better do this so you can see what's
going on um probably one of the
the top phrases here is women's
and what i can do is i can take you know
there that count there and i'm going to
put it off to the side
so i know that uh in a phrase
the hiking boots for women actually i
can see it here uh
i can see women's hiking boots showing
up there
now i can also look at on this side
for women and i can take
that keyword count and put it over here
actually
so this gives me a sense of people are
using this phrase as kind of an anchor
and the phrase women is on either side
however uh you know i see four women
women
women's now to google that's all going
to be counted as the same
this is the big difference in doing
keyword research here
is i'm going to see more variations if i
were to do this same research in
google's keyword tool
which by the way i will say i have not
used
google's keyword tool for keyword
research now for well over five years
you just don't get the dynamics of the
words
google will combine these three keywords
and call them the same thing
and give you the same search count very
similar to this uh as you can see as i
said
day by day our these keyword resources
are flying away
um same here women's hiking look at the
we've got like three different ways here
women hiking boots
women's hiking boots women's without
apostrophe hiking boots
google is going to show you one phrase
it's not going to show you the three
different phrases that are here so i can
get a better understanding using a
keyword tool like this
some of the nuances within the phrase
whereas google's going to combine that
into one phrase and that's all you get
so from here i want to get a sense of
what comes prior to the keyword and
after the keyword
and let it build uh so for example uh
this phrase here waterproof that is a
great thing to know
waterproof comes there uh and then also
um yeah and then women was on the other
side of that phrase
um and then the same thing here it was
both
women's waterproof
hiking boots uh so i can get a sense now
when someone is describing an attribute
such as waterproof
tradition and i'll confirm that as i go
through here it looks to me like
waterproof always comes first
and hiking boots comes second and and
i'll confirm that as i go
through here so what i'm trying to do is
build kind of a mental
model or a word cloud of
how people use phrases and where they
come
in relation to my core key phrase
such as hiking boots uh and as i go
through i'm gonna
you know very quickly go through here
and see um
you know here's another example women's
winter hiking boots
so i would probably add that here as
well
so and that kind of confirms for me as i
see here the attribute always tends to
come prior to the keyword
and then i'll probably see that with the
color as well
color as an attribute will probably come
forward now what i'm looking for to see
what will come as a suffix what will
come later after
the term hiking boots uh and i don't see
a lot of that however
where i do see it are in the very
specific
product names now what's interesting
here uh is so like the renegade gtx the
quest
4d gtx those are specific
product names so now what that tells me
is i need to add another column here and
that will be
product searches that means they are
looking specifically like this merrell
moab 2.
that is a specific product brand name
and search and so especially if i have
those products
i want to nail that down and be sure
i am doing that so that's it
i'll add that in there
and so that's my next step is is doing
some organization to find out
where these play in and how people are
formulating
their phrases any questions uh to this
point about what i'm doing here
yeah i believe there are um
so manpreet asks what happens if a
keyword
has more than one product assigned to it
and i believe this is the process you're
going through to show
how to distinguish
different specific products
that branch off of the main keyword
yes absolutely that's what i'm looking
for is the different attributes and how
people
search for those attributes and really
what i'm looking for is
the attribute in relation to the core
phrase
so hiking boots is my let me get my
cursor over there hiking boots is my
core
phrase and that's what i want to look at
and see
how are people formulating this so now
and so i'm not just looking for this to
to copy and paste my keywords into my
into my site
i can now look at this and find a model
or a framework that when i'm optimizing
the
thousands of products on my site that
may not be found in keyword research or
i may not get a guide
now i can create a you know
uh women's or men's uh
attribute one attribute to product name
and i can almost create my page titles
as well as my product names
uh i could i could just set it up and
pull it all out of a database and have
it populate
uh automatically instead of going
through and optimizing
every single page title or every single
product page
if i can figure out the the steps or or
the model
i can just create those categories and
and let my database fill in the gaps
and that way you know it's taken care of
so that's one way i i learn from this uh
because especially if we're dealing with
pages with with hundreds of thousands or
thousands of
of product pages that's a lot of work
and if you can make your database do a
lot of the work for you
that's what helps okay that that gets to
uh one of the other questions that i
think we
might want to explore later having to do
with how to incorporate the results of
the research into the
the website and the pages um yes yeah
because that's basically the whole
purpose of the exercise is to improve
your website pages improves your
content um and social media as well so
um do you have a comment on on
how this applies in in the context of
social media
is this something that social media
marketers
yeah for so yeah exactly for social
media marketing like i said when i'm
looking
when i'm uh looking for social media
i'm i use social media as a way of
extending my
my content social media i use it with a
content marketing plan
so for example when i am and let me
pull up a couple of things here to get a
sense of this
so for example if i were to create a
an article uh and a video about
because there's a big opportunity here
in best hiking boots
best hiking boots for women best hiking
boots for men best hiking boots
right there that i can probably turn
that into
10 articles and 10 videos or more
so from a content marketing standpoint i
now have direction as far as what people
want to see and how i can create content
about that
when i create a video about or
or an article about best hiking boots
and or the five best hiking boots for
women
once i create that video i'm going to
take snippets of it
i'm going to take screen captures of it
i will also get
brand pictures and i will use that on my
social media
and so i will use social media as a
distribution mechanism
saying you know getting ready to buy
some boots don't make this mistake
uh you know or put out a brand name it's
number two
find out why so i'm going to use social
media to direct
people back to my site to see the video
or read the article and but i'm also
going to be very aware of when people
are searching
because now and let me i'm going to
bring this over here so we can see this
as well
so for example um and i'm going to add
another here
this is why i love google trends i'm
going to take these keywords and i'm
going to apply them to google trends
and and i'm looking here over the past
five years and the reason why i'll do a
five-year window
is i'm looking to see if there is a
specific
trend every year for the past five years
if i can see the trend appearing every
year for five years
that means it's going to happen again
that's what i'm looking for
it means it's repeatable and if it's
repeatable i can plan on it and i add
that into my
media or content calendar i add that
into my content calendar because
now i know when interest is at its
highest
and when the interest is at its highest
is when i'm going to be the most
active on social media pointing people
back to my content
such as videos how-to videos how to fit
your boot how to get the right boot
how to get the right boot for where
you're going there's difference in boots
if you're going to a mountain as opposed
to if you're going to
a desert uh and so all of my activity
i'm going
to increase my social media activity
and where i'm pointing people based on
the trends so for example here
hiking boots is a general category it is
at its highest look at this november
december
why is that people are buying hiking
boots for people
uh that that's one of the things we
found out is
that hikers or or active
outdoor people they buy their own things
uh
and other people friends family will buy
them hiking gear
uh in november or december uh they buy
for each other
but also the next biggest trend is in
late
may late may is when people are gearing
up
for their summer treks and for their
summer hiking
so i know that this this kind of spring
spike and then there is a decem a
november december spike
so that lets me know exactly when people
are
starting to look for new products and
and what they're doing now i'm going to
pull out hiking boots simply because
that is making everything else look
really small
so we pull that out now look at this
best hiking boots and women's hiking
boots and they both
follow a very similar trend um
again november december we have a spike
and then
earlier in the year uh here we have like
a
june july i think that was yeah june
july
uh we see another spike in this and then
another spike in december
again going back here we are in in may
we see these spikes so
that's what we're looking for is the
repeatable spikes
that's how we know when to start up when
our optimization
should be in full swing and also in
social media
if we're seeing a spike in search
activity we know
that people are going to be talking
about it on social media and they're
going to be looking at it so i'm going
to use my
my paid search ads i'm going to use my
paid media my retargeting
is going to be at its highest during
those peaks
because i know that people are searching
at that point
okay um kind of a related question
and i know that there's no way to look
at trends over time for this because
it's not a time trend but
what is your opinion about localizing
with the
things like hiking boots in colorado for
example
is that something that people are
finding yes
yes it is very useful um especially if
you
are focusing on a local or regional
audience if you are a local business or
a regional business
absolutely you and and that is one of
the columns
let me uh let me bring that down here i
i did not get it
it's amazing how fast this hour goes
stewart i gotta say that
we may have to bring this up i'm going
to create another column and i usually
do this and thank you for bringing that
up whoever you are
fantastic question region location
all right i'm also going to create
another one for time
because as people are doing searches
there they will also let you know where
they
are if they're looking in a specific
area or
if there is a certain date or trend or
time uh that they're looking for so
i'm absolutely going to use this
to to optimize and find if someone is
looking for a region or location
as a matter of fact let me let me bring
this up here where did that go
it's a great looking cup though oh thank
you yeah that's
all right um so for example if i'm in
google trends
uh this will break down by state
now what we're what it's showing here is
the amount of searches the percentage of
searches based on population
uh so for example uh let me pull up
colorado here
um what we can see here is
the percentages out of searches for all
two terms in colorado
just gives you a sense um that based on
population hawaii has the
highest searches uh so we can get down
and even break it down
by state uh and you can see search
interest in colorado here for example is
really high
we can really get a sense here so google
trends will break this down by state or
by
region uh if you're in a different
country it will break it down
by the different regions within the
country or cities there
or metro areas so it's a great way to do
that
um also let me bring up did i
yeah i x out of that um even in the
keyword research tool
uh you can also add in specifically uh
if you're looking at a location and it
will give you the keywords for that
state or region and you can add them in
there
absolutely from a local optimization
standpoint
yeah definitely keep those in your
titles and your descriptions and
everything about your business
so stuart i think we have a couple of
minutes uh we can answer some questions
and we may have to uh
follow this up on another another master
class here
i would i would love to do that um matt
to schedule uh another master class to
continue on
with some of the other uh demonstrations
you wanted to do um
we have an interesting question from
sajid who is a very sharp-eyed viewer
and uh he said the fact the first three
word combinations in one of your
results had the same number exact same
number
of 135 042
results um it signifies that word
tracker is getting the same google data
um where google combines them into one
combination is that
a correct interpretation yeah google
will combine those
into one number uh and yeah because
google is the primary source of data
uh again everything is extrapolated
they're running an algorithm
and giving you an estimated amount
now here's here's how to use this
uh let me let me show here's here's the
key
where's my where did that go let me make
a quick announcement while you're doing
that
all right so we are at the end of the
first hour
here uh which is the entire scheduled
run of the the webinar
so we understand if people have a hard
stop
and need to drop off we are going to be
sending out
um a link to the webinar recording
for however long it goes and
we will also be sending out proof of
attendance certificates to everybody who
made it
to this mark so um
don't worry about dropping off if you
have to
um but if you can please stay and
uh we'll take just a few more questions
from that
don't want to keep him here sorry
oh okay great question about the counts
and and if you have to leave give me 30
seconds because this will blow your mind
all right i don't look
these are not true okay
these are estimates so how do we use
this number
we use it in comparison what i'm looking
at here is these are thirteen thousand
this next group is fifty four thousand
or excuse me that's a hundred and thirty
thousand
and this is fifty four thousand what i'm
looking at
is the ratio all right what this
is showing me is hey you know what
women's hiking boots
is search vastly more than men's hiking
boots
in fact it's searched almost three times
as more
that's what i'm doing with the keyword
counts i'm not looking at the hard
numbers i'm looking
at the ratio of women's to men's
and seeing that there's three times as
many searches for women's as men's
that's the key when looking at your
keyword data
okay um a question from josh
would would it be why is he used the
competitor's keywords research
to feed into your own keywords uh as for
example
taking text from their home page or
other
metadata from their site and
putting it into your own keyword list as
a way to
start i think it's a great idea um you
can
you know in a lot of the tools like
ahrefs or
some of your uh your seo management
tools
you can put in competitor websites and
they'll scrape the data so that you can
see what they're doing
i think it's a great place to start i
would not
duplicate all right definitely don't do
that because
what you're going to find and i see this
more and more
people tend to think that competitors
are doing better
all the time we just have this sense
that somebody else must be doing it
better and
even if they have a couple of higher
ranks we tend to think they know what
they're doing and they're doing it
better
and that's not always the case
do your own research use their words as
a starting point but get it you've got
to do the research
use it to inform you but don't make it
the ultimate authority
of and don't assume that they're doing
better i've seen this time and time
again people assume just because they're
ranking higher that they're doing better
the problem is
you don't see the ultimate measure which
is their profitability
the ultimate measure of a good business
is how profitable
it is and so many times you
overestimate what other people are doing
and when i get in and i see
not just the analytics but when i see
how a business is running
you want to look for a profitable
sustainable business
and it doesn't matter if someone
outranks you for a couple words
you want to be profitable and
sustainable and that is the key
to being successful excellent
um we have a question from our linkedin
audience uh
nishka says i'll be switching my career
from japanese interpreter
to digital marketing
so what certifications would uh
initiative need for that
well uh you simply have to look around
the simply learned site and uh you'll
see some certifications there
uh i'm a firm believer in the omcp the
online marketing certified professional
because that certifies you in a number
of disciplines
of search engine optimization paid
search
but i will say if you have mastery in
more than one language
you may also want to investigate uh
working with some agencies or firms
that do global seo because they are
constantly looking for multilingual
people
that can understand this and apply this
and i will say
the experience you get working at an
agency
with different kinds of businesses and
different applications
you can't duplicate that uh you will
learn so much at an
agency so before going out on your own
take the time to learn from other people
and get as much experience
as you can get paid to get experience
okay
um but i will say if you if you have
mastery of more than one language
you your skill set simply there
with digital marketing is going to make
you a great asset
excellent um slightly related to that
colette asks
if you know of any tools that can track
arabic keywords for the middle east
and north africa region um
great great question um i've used word
tracker
uh for the arabic region um now it will
do
a kind of a combination of english and
arabic um i've used that i think ahrefs
is doing that ver
as well uh so that's something that uh
you can look into but
like i said most of them have a free
trial
but if you get into the data and look it
will list country specific
but be sure you not only look at the
country but the languages offered
um we have a number of questions about
the
native google tools like google keyword
planner
yeah and what is
your how would you compare those to
some of the other tools that you've
discussed is it
is can somebody get by with google
google the keyword
planner or do does that
just have too many limitations to be
entirely useful
yeah i haven't like i said i haven't
used google keyword tools
uh for years now simply because
uh they have not um
they're showing you what they want you
to see
um that that's really the case there
um they're not showing you
it's so limited and and put it this way
so
google google's an advertising company
google makes almost 90 of its revenue
from ads all right and so
when you go research keywords as an
advertiser
google's going to show you the keywords
and keyword combinations that
they want you to bid on because when you
bid on them
i mean they have the inventory and
they're showing you
you're doing research but they're not
showing you the whole inventory they're
not showing you
they're showing you what they want you
to see as an advertiser
and so it's so limited
and and like i said every year it
becomes more and more
limited what they let you see and so i i
just
i'm not a fan of the keyword tools that
google gives you
um it just i every time i get in and use
them i'm more and more disappointed
yep um
i have a hypothetical from from ancho
who asks and
i'm not sure how how this necessarily
relates but he he
he offers a couple of options which one
would be better
um best hiking boots for men
and then another term best hiking boots
for women and then
red red best hiking boots or would
you combine them into something like
best hiking boots for men women red
i would not combine them um
now what do you my question would be
what are you doing
now um because if you're selling this if
this is e-commerce
you're going to have separate men's and
women's sections and then you're going
to have a specific boot
and then if that boot is offered in red
that that will be a feature
an attribute of the product so
i i you know depending upon you know
whether red makes it into a title or
makes it it's mainly going to be a
product attribute
now if i'm creating an article
or a video about the best hiking boots
for
men that's one video if i'm creating a
video about the best hiking boots for
women
that's another video if i best hiking
boots
for mountains best hiking boots for
desert best hiking boots for hawaii you
know
all of a sudden now i'm well beyond
uh you know thinking about specific
attributes
now i'm looking and because the
attribute and the location
of how people will use these hiking
boots that's searched on much
more than a color and so i'm going to
use that in my content marketing and
honestly out of best hiking boots i
could really that's why i have this
i could probably come up with 30 video
ideas
uh for my content marketing and every
single one of them is going to help me
optimize
it's going to help me with my paid
search it's going to help me with my
social
and so that's what i'm using when i'm
doing a lot of keyword research is
what kind of content can i produce that
people want
to see what questions am i answering
excellent um
i've i think i'm going to close out with
two
questions um from people in different
situations sanjeev
has an ethnic food commerce ethnic food
e-commerce portal an app
for b2b for for trade for restaurants
for convenience stores that type of
thing
um which is a great business
yeah how would he differentiate
between the brand led keywords versus
wholesale food
category keywords wow
wow um that's amazing because
you're kind of limited to the search
function within that
app um
you know unless you can get some data
about how that search function works
uh because i'd love to know how your b2b
customers are
using it to search um
you know are because that that would be
my question is are they are they
searching generally are they searching
for brand
my guess that they would probably be
searching generally and then look to see
what brands are available
that's how most people tend to function
as we we search based on our need
first and then brand we will
will we'll learn what brands are there
and then if we if we have a brand
preference
we'll use it um but ninety percent of
the time
we don't have that brand in mind we're
looking for the general product
uh and so i would kind of go with that
but unless you could
get some insight into how that search
function works within that
app or within that that closed system
captioning not
for people who are available search
engines
um how they would find his portal and
how they would find his app
um oh okay yeah but but the other aspect
of that too that
as you discussed it it made me also
realize
that in that particular industry
um it might be important for a
business to look at a brand and then
evaluate what its product line is so
in that particular case the customer
might
actually look brand first in some
instances but i think
um your interpretation of the
people are going to look for the
category of the type of food product
um and then look at brands and then
probably in in that particular
case they'll loop back to see what other
products that brand carries
to finish that cycle so that's yeah
that's a it's a really great
uh question thank you
um and then we have
uh davon the last question he is a watch
blogger which i assume that he is
blogging about wristwatches and
timepieces and the fascinated by all of
this
i love it love it so the keyword he
finds are very
limited with high competition is there a
way that he should proceed
to to solve the problem in that
environment
um that is a great great question
and you're going to run into this
especially with very
specific um
very specific industry types are very
specific where there's
there's not a lot and and this is what
google
runs on google runs on
high levels and that's where it's very
effective in doing things like this so
wherever you're in a product or an
industry
where there's low levels of searches or
um
it's very limited uh you're gonna get
limited data you're gonna get so
a lot of this you probably i that's
where i would focus on learning from
your analytics
uh and i would make sure and now this
may get into some advanced stuff i would
be looking
into i would connect your your bing
webmaster tools
your google webmaster tools uh
your you know any tools that will give
you a sense and because both being in
google when you connect the webmaster
tools
you'll get some additional keywords that
people are using to find
you uh i i love how bing will even show
what searches you're you're appearing
for as well as
your click-through rate and get a sense
of that so that's one way you can get
access
into some of the keywords that search
engines use
um but that's that's kind of one thing
that i would look at to see
um how i can get some additional data i
i
would also you know that's where some
competitor research may help
and look around and uh
but one of the things i would also look
at
um and that would be
some of the the seo companies like in
ahrefs
um moz tools
trying to think of a couple others um
they will also show backlinks uh they
will catalog
all the links that are going to a
competitor site your site
so it'll show the results of who's
linking to your blog
and that's great pr when you see who's
linking to your articles and
and why they're linking it's a great way
to start a relationship
and uh go look at those articles of
who's linking to you and see what
they're saying
it's a great way of kind of getting a
sense of what the market
is all about excellent um i i kind of
fib because we do have one last question
from the linkedin audience
uh great napoleon asks
um how would
how are podcasts helpful in inbound
market marketing
um can you
comment on that or give some use cases
for that wow
um
for inbound marketing um i've not
seen it so much used and and being a
podcaster myself i'll kind of talk from
my own experience
i don't see it so much as an inbound
tool um i find it more as
a nurturing tool that once i have
you know for example i just did the
webinar i just put my slide up with the
many ways you could contact me and i had
my podcast on there
you didn't discover me through the
podcast you discovered me through a
webinar
and now i'm telling you if you want more
content if you want more
you know marketing insight go to the
podcast
so for me it's much more of a nurturing
tool
uh it helps me grow and nurture
my audience and that helps
bring in additional you know it builds
loyalty it builds
builds more relationships uh
podcasting as the inbound tool
i think is very limited because people
have to find it somehow
and right now podcast discoverability is
kind of tricky it's kind of hard
uh the vast majority of people will will
subscribe to a new podcast
solely based on word of mouth
recommendations
um when they go very rarely to people
go to a podcast like on spotify or apple
and decide i'm going to listen to that
one that one and that one they listen
for recommendations from their friends
from colleagues
or like this if they hear someone that
they like and they happen to have a
podcast they'll subscribe
so i from an inbound standpoint i i
i'm sure there are some that might be
doing it
well i've just not known about it i see
it more as a nurturing and
uh as a as a community builder
rather than an inbound tool thank you
um so this has been a wonderful session
i
i always feel guilty at the end of these
sessions because
we invite people to put in their
questions we get
a hundred or more questions and we can't
answer them all
so i apologize uh on behalf of simple
learn for all the people
who asked a question that matt couldn't
get to today
um again um it's pretty clear that this
topic deserves
another go around so we hope that you'll
come back in a for a future version of
our part two of this master class
and maybe you'll get a chance for
matt to get to that question right now
well i will
i will say stuart what we can do is
we'll go ahead and collect all these
questions
and then i would recommend that uh uh
subscribe to the simply learn
uh blog subscribe to simply learn social
because we could always get to answering
these questions and publish those out
yes that is an excellent point because
we do use
the interest level of the questions
to help us decide
what topics to cover in our blog our
resources section of our website
absolutely yeah so
thank you for the reminder and i'm going
to
share a couple of last
things to close out the webinar we've
just finished the question and answer so
first off i want to say thank you to
matt
um and then i'd like to do
a quick final poll
to ask people about what they think
would be the most interesting things to
study for
for their digital marketing career so
i'll open the poll
this one is multiple choice so you can
click on more than one
there's different disciplines within
digital marketing
and
we do offer courses in all of these
through simply learn
we also offer
combined comprehensive programs like our
postgraduate program in digital
marketing
which is in partnership with purdue
university
and so we have the resources and the
tools available for you to pursue
each of these areas or all of them
and in three two one
i will share the result of the poll
and predictably
seo is a very popular category
as it should be yes as it should be it's
interesting to see that the
content marketing and social marketing
are the the next
two most popular so um all of those
are important areas in digital marketing
because it's becoming a
uh you know kind of a 360 degree view
um of your interaction with
your audience and your customers and
so with that i'm going to
[Music]
after saying thank you again to matt
and allowing you to say thank you to the
audience matt
all right thank you everyone really
appreciate the questions fantastic
questions
and uh yeah uh with the questions and i
i will say like i said when i do keyword
research it would be four or five days
so thank you for your patience we tried
to condense this as much as possible but
looks like we might have to have a
follow-up
but really appreciate your time today
thanks
and just want to mention that we
do have a fairly new program it's been
running for
since about november of last year and it
is called skill up
and skill up is uh acts the free access
to some of our
instructional content over 600 skills
over a thousand hours of video content
available
um again access this program is free
and what we've just added to the program
is
uh completion certificates so as you
complete these self-study courses you
will get a
completion certificate and that's
something that you can share
on your cv or social media and
i'm going to drop the link into the chat
so that you can all see how to access
the skill up page i'm going to
announce the next webinar next week is
not digital marketing
it is problem solving
for business processes and personal
friend of mine
dr len bertain we talking about how
important it is
to solve business problems before you
try to automate them
everybody talks about robotic process
automation digital transformation
converting processes to digital but you
don't
want to automate a process that
hasn't already been optimized or you
don't want to automate a problem that
you haven't solved
so he will talk about
how to solve the business problem and
the process problem
before you apply the digital technology
and
here in the chat is the link to that
and finally
you can connect with simply learn by
using app simply learn on facebook
twitter
uh search for simply learn on linkedin
and um those are all the same ways that
you can get to map right
um matt bailey
why why don't you go ahead and give your
social media handles
all right um i'm gonna put into the chat
uh a
recent podcast i did uh on keywords
uh specifically we talked about keyword
research and how important keywords are
so i put that in the chat there
uh you can go right to my megaphone
account to
see and uh subscribe from there uh on
linkedin i
am matt bailey link matt bailey sl
on on linkedin uh so feel free to
contact me as
there and uh i don't do too much on
twitter
uh or facebook uh i'm i'm a little bit
protected there i i focus everything on
business
uh that's the primary place and uh
thanks again
all right uh thank you all for being
here today
um thank you again matt for for a
marvelous session and this really
concludes the webinar so
we invite you now to log off of webex
and we will be sending out a link
to a recording of this session so that
you can review the material
and that'll come by email tomorrow we'll
be sending out
um proof of attendance certificates to
people who have
stayed with us through the live uh
webinar
and we will be mailing those out over
the weekend
so check your email for those
and we look forward to seeing you at
future sessions
with simplylearn thanks thank you
everyone
you